- [sighs]
I COURTED SUZANNE
FOR AN EXCRUCIATING 13 MONTHS
BEFORE SHE ALLOWED ME TO BE
PHYSICALLY INTIMATE WITH HER.
WHATEVER MAGIC
I WORKED THEN,
I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO CONDENSE
INTO THE TIME IT TAKES
TO EAT THIS MEAL
OF AMERICAN BISTRO FOOD.
OH.
- HI.
- YES, HELLO.
- I'M ASHLEY.
AND THIS IS MY BODYGUARD.
- OH, OKAY.
WONDERFUL. LISTEN, HEY,
I GOT YOU THESE FLOWERS.
THESE ARE FOR YOU.
- OH, THANK YOU.
- YES, IT'S GOOD.
YOU LOOK ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
- OH, THANK YOU.
- YES, THANK YOU
FOR LOOKING SO BEAUTIFUL.
- AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR $70,000 CONTRIBUTION.
- WELL, YOU KNOW,
I HAVE A SON
WHO'S EXTREMELY SHORT
FOR HIS AGE.
- OH, SO YOU'RE MARRIED?
- QUITE THE CONTRARY.
I AM RECENTLY DIVORCED
AND GETTING OUT THERE.
SO YOUR TIMING IS PRETTY GOOD.
YES.
YEAH.
- [chuckles nervously]
- YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
I DABBLE IN PALM READING.
MAY I?
- OH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GOOD.
I'M GOOD. I DON'T REALLY BELIEVE
IN THAT STUFF.
- OH, WELL, IT'S MAINLY
JUST SORT OF FOR FUN,
TO TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
YOUR HEART LINE.
- NO.
- YEAH.
MM, OKAY.
YEAH.
MY--MY LOVE LINE,
IF IT'S THIS ONE, IS ALL--
GOES ALL THE WAY AROUND.
YOU SURE YOU DON'T WANT
A PALM READ--
- I'M--I'M GOOD.
- UM, YOU--I IMAGINE
THAT BEING A CELEBRITY
IS VERY, VERY STRESSFUL.
- NO, ACTUALLY,
IT'S REALLY FUN.
- WITH CERTAIN STRESSES,
IN TERMS OF
KEEPING UP PUBLIC APPEARANCES
AND--AND ALL THAT.
- NO.
I-I REALLY ENJOY IT.
I LOVE IT.
- WELL, NO WONDER
YOU'RE CARRYING ALL THAT TENSION
IN YOUR SHOULDERS.
- I'M CARRYING--NO.
NO, NO, NO.
- SO WHY DON'T I SEE
IF I CAN HELP YOU
WITH THAT?
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU DON'T NEED TO GET UP.
- NO, WELL, I'LL--
I THINK I'LL JUST GIVE YOU
A LITTLE BACK RUB HERE.
IT SHOULD'VE COME
AS NO SURPRISE
THAT MISS TISDALE
WAS ACTING COY.
TO A CELEBRITY,
AN EVENING OF SEX
IS A COVETED PRIZE
THAT CANNOT BE HANDED OUT
TO JUST ANYONE
WITH NO APPARENT BENEFIT
IN THE FORM OF DRUGS
OR CAREER ADVANCEMENT.
- I'M OKAY.
- OKAY.
- I'M JUST EXCITED FOR DINNER.
- GOOD.
SO, UH...
- OH, GOOD.
THANKS.
- OKAY.
I'M JUST GONNA BE
VERY BLUNT WITH YOU.
- OH, BOY.
- MY INTEREST IN THIS DATE
ACTUALLY HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE FOOD,
EVEN THOUGH
THIS RIB TASTER FOR TWO
IS DEFINITELY CALLING TO ME,
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
BUT WHAT I'M SAYING IS
IF YOU ARE INTERESTED
IN GETTING OUT OF HERE
AND GOING STRAIGHT TO DESSERT...
[cell phone rings]
- OH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I AM SO SORRY.
I HAVE TO TAKE THIS.
HELLO?
- FAKE PHONE CALL,
FAKE PHONE CALL,
FAKE PHONE CALL.
- WHAT?
- FAKE PHONE CALL,
FAKE PHONE CALL,
FAKE PHONE CALL.
- RIGHT NOW?
- FAKE PHONE CALL,
FAKE PHONE CALL,
FAKE PHONE CALL.
- OH, MY GOD, OKAY.
I AM SO SORRY.
A BAD THING HAPPENED,
AND IT'S AN EMERGENCY.
AND I'VE GOT TO GO.
I'M SO SORRY.
- NO PROBLEM.
LISTEN, AS I WAS SAYING--
- NO, NO, NO, NO, PLEASE--
PLEASE, STAY HERE.
JUST ENJOY YOUR DINNER.
- I HAVE NO INTEREST
IN THE FOOD AT ALL.
- EAT YOUR DINNER.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR $70,000 CONTRIBUTION.